Martin brunt Sky News
thousands of nurses will strike for the
May bank holiday after one of the
country's largest unions voted to reject
a government pay offer but the rcn's
decision put them at odds with another
health union Unison whose members
accepted the five percent wage increase
and this time around the industrial
action nurses will provide no cover for
emergency care or cancer Wards as our
health correspondent Ashish Joshi
reports
these were historic scenes nurses on the
picket line for the first time I am
really pleased to be with you all in
this historic day and now they will be
seen again after the RCN rejected the
government's payoffer addressing her
members chief executive Pat Cullen said
she has never been prouder but Mark like
many of his Union colleagues wants
answers patcon and the RCN Council have
a lot of hard questions to answer as to
why they recommended this deal in the
first place when
um you know so many of the membership
obviously didn't want it and rejected it
the offer not only rejected but more
strike dates announced for the end of
April with a ballot on further action to
come this offer was not enough for our
members and it is now down to the
government to listen to the voice of
Nursing and put a better offer on the
table they need to restore the nurse's
pay
it's a decision that puts the RCN one of
the largest Health unions in conflict
with another Unison its members voted in
favor if we've got a split decision on
the staff Council then government will
have to look at that and make a balanced
decision about whether they proceed to
implement but if you know if the
majority of health workers are saying
they want to accept the offer then
government could be in a tricky position
the health secretary Steve Barkley says
the Unison result proves the offer is
fair and reasonable calling the rcn's
decision hugely disappointing and
concerning for patients we have two of
the biggest Health unions at odds with
each other with the other health unions
still Consulting with their members
about what to do with the government's
payoffer we're in limbo until the end of
the month when all of the organizations
will go back to the government and
hopefully then there will be some sort
of resolution the Us in will ballot its
members about strike action for the last
six months of this year and that brings
about the prospect of nurses and Junior
doctors standing together on the picket
line for the first time
Mark is ready to strike again but
despite his Union's result he could yet
have a deal he rejected forced on him
Ashish Joshy Sky News
we'll prove you wrong that was the
defiant message delivered by the
chancellor in Washington today as he met
the head of the international monetary
fund Jeremy Hunt is predicting that the
UK economy will bounce back but he'll
also be hoping that his gamble to resist
pay Rises for public sector workers will
also pay off Jeremy Hunt has been
speaking to our economics and data
editor at Conway
a rare Glimpse inside a private meeting
in Washington between the UK team and
the head of the international monetary
fund we know that
being a
very uh
determined there is clearly tension here
the IMF thinks Britain will be the
weakest economy in the G7 this year the
chancellor begs to differ we're very
focused on proven you wrong excellent
can you explain what does that mean what
are we talking about here well the IMF
head said to me that she very much hopes
I do prove her wrong um I think the
context here Ed is that last year we had
the fastest growing G7 economy so um we
did very well last year we have so far
avoided recession this year so the
economy has shown resilience but we want
to be growing faster but do you think
that those IMF forecasts are wrong is
that your is that your hunt well
um the office for Budget responsibility
which is the government's official
forecaster has much more optimistic
forecasts so if you're asking me which I
think is more likely to be the case I
would go with the obr but the latest
vote from nurses on further strikes
won't help what we say is that we will
talk about anything except a deal that
would mean that inflation is entrenched
and we're having the same discussion
this time next year because that's the
root cause of people's anger it's seeing
inflation above 10 the cost of the
weekly shop going up is there a concern
here about what this means for
the Health Service itself I urge people
are still voting for this pay deal to
recognize the fact that union leaders
say it's fair and reasonable patients
want the NHS to be back to normal and it
will be better for staff as well
Britain's not alone in facing these
problems it's just that it seems that
bit worse in the UK right now on growth
on strikes on the cost of living in his
effort to prove the fund wrong the
chancellor may have his work cut out Ed
Conway Sky News in Washington
to France now where after weeks of
protests president macron's
controversial plans to raise the
retirement age have been approved by a
French Court the bill will be signed
into law in the coming days as Skies
Lisa Holland reports now from Paris
all eyes were on paris's constitutional
Council where the decision would be made
for police spotters the view from the
roof waiting to see how France would
react
getting the clothes shop next door we
found Allah who believes these
incendiary days could have been avoided
I can understand people but don't accept
it but maybe it's necessary but it's the
government to explain why with correctly
France's president Emmanuel macron had
begun the day on a jovial visit to see
reconstruction work after the 2019 fire
at Notre Dame Cathedral
for him the day would also end in Smiles
with validation of his reforms he
insists France can't afford to keep the
pension age at 62 and it must be raised
to 64.
across Paris outside the town hall
workers from the left-wing cgt Union
gathered bitterly disappointed but
vowing to fight on president macron's
legal crisis may have ended but his
political crisis has not there are still
a lot of angry people in France who
refuse to accept his pension reforms
demonstrators have taken to the streets
every week since mid-January strikes
have hit France hard Stefan valdon works
on the railways as a ticket inspector
taking industrial action means he hasn't
been paid I'm very disappointed I'm very
angry because we're on strike for four
weeks it's very difficult for us there's
a sense from some they may need new
tactics
I don't know how long
and can
and with no reaction
for the old tactics of a hardcore
prepared to take on the riot police saw
skirmishes inside streets in Paris
France comes out of the pension ruling
fragmented over the question of how long
people should have to work be so Holland
Sky News Paris
two serving metropolitan police officers
have been dismissed over discriminatory
messages they sent to colleagues in a
WhatsApp group the two former police
officers were found guilty of gross
misconduct over racist homophobic and
sexist messages they shared between May
2016 and June 2018.
the U.S high court has temporarily
blocked restrictions to access on the
abortion pill mifopristone the Supreme
Court today decided to temporarily keep
In-Place rules for use of an abortion
drug while it takes time to consider the
issues raised in a court challenge
there are Smiles of relief as the
exchange of more than 800 prisoners
linked to the long-running war in Yemen
began today the United Nations broke a
deal has been in the works for months
the three-day exchange will see
prisoners transported between Saudi
Arabia and Yemen's capitals thanar
thank you Sally you join us again in
Ballina where in the past 10 minutes Joe
Biden has finished speaking finish his
address to the tens of thousands of
people gathered at some murders
Cathedrals the culmination of President
Biden's four-day visit now earlier today
he was seen wiping away tears after
meeting the priest who performed the
last rights for his son Beau Biden
before he died in 2015. here's our
Island correspondent Stephen Murphy
this was always going to be an emotional
Journey but even the most powerful man
in the world didn't see this coming
on his visit to County Mayo's knock
Shrine Joe Biden was asked if he'd like
to meet the Irish chaplain who while
attached to the U.S military gave his
son Beau Biden the last right as he died
from brain cancer in 2015. it was a
chance meeting away from the cameras
that left the U.S president in tears
father Gibbons the priest said then well
the priesthood and the priesthood kind
of supported your son works here at
knock and he didn't know I worked there
so then he's into over for me to go and
see him and when I when I see them he
was a little bit more a bit emotional
you know we the last time we met was
when the son was very ill eight years
ago after prayer and reflection
President Biden visited a hospice with
another connection to a son a plaque at
its entrance dedicated to Beau Biden's
memory Joe Biden had turned the sod on
the center on a private visit in 2017.
it was an emotional start to the day but
it ended in a party this is the
ancestral Biden home of Ballina and
they'd been waiting for this since their
favorite son was elected president it's
good to be here and to show people that
I have met him because a lot of people
might think what are you going down for
again but I want to meet him even a
third time and the picture I will always
treasure it's strange that he's so close
to our home you know when we're used to
seeing him on television but um yeah it
is a bit surreal that would be kind of
this close to him because we've got to
see him on the news
[Music]
President Biden spoke in front of a
cathedral built with 27 000 bricks
supplied by his ancestor Edward Blewett
in 1828
as in labor I'm sure Edward imagine that
one day his family would worship here
that his children will be baptized here
like his son Patrick was
and that future generations of his
family would Mark the Milestones of
their lives here in his sturdy walls
but I doubt he ever imagined his great
great great grandson will return 200
years later as president of the United
States of America
this was a rousing end to a grand tour
of Ireland that mixed the deeply
personal with the political Joe Biden
leaves this island a U.S president more
connected than ever with the land of his
forefathers Stephen Murphy Sky News
Ballina County Mayo
well our International Affairs Edison
Dominique white corn is still here with
me uh Dominic uh so that's it President
Biden is going to be soon wheels up back
to the US to deal with that leak of
Pentagon documents how do you think he
will assess his time here in Ireland I I
think that speech wasn't his best I
think it was a kind of rather a jumbled
uh collection of all his Greatest Hits
but in no particular order and we heard
about his belief in Hope Liberty greater
dignity possibility humanity and courage
these are the things of his visit but
the themes of his political uh career
and then we had a very long uh kind of
story of his life of the bluitts of the
Finnegans going back to the 1840s in
Greater detail than we've had all the
way through this trip so it's a story of
the speech for consumption here but also
for consumption back home because that
story of immigrants or people escaping
economic hardship in the old world and
going to the new world and building a a
new life for themselves is something
that millions of Americans appeal to and
it resonates with whether they're Irish
or not so it's it's a speech I think of
a politician who is certainly thinking
about preparing for announcing to run
again
um for re-election uh something he's
hinted at I think they're looking at him
tonight you know he looks tired and to
be honest he looks old and you have to
really wonder whether he's got what it
takes the energy and the Vigor needs to
campaign to be president again in his
80s at this time of his life we're
expecting to see an announcement from
him at some point raising Dominic for
now thank you so much sure that is all
from us here in Ballina as President Joe
Biden makes his way back to the United
States he's got plenty to deal with once
he gets back stateside not least that
Pentagon leagues but after four day here
in Ireland arriving for the anniversary
of the Good Friday agreement and it's a
serious speeches and tonight a personal
speech given to the thousands here in
Ballin our President Biden is on his
back to the United States from the
entire team here in County mayor it's
back to Sally now in London
Kamali thanks very much
some space news now it may be a day late
but a European spacecraft is tonight on
its way to Jupiter on a mission to
explore whether there is any life on the
planet's ocean-bearing moons The Voyage
will last eight years and cost 14
billion pounds as our Science and
Technology editor Tom Clarke reports
good life lurk in Hidden oceans on
Jupiter's moons
the juice mission is finally on its way
to find out
launch was an anxious moment at Imperial
College in London scientists here built
and will operate one of the mission's
key instruments
to happen we had to wait another day
it's finally gone we're so happy to see
it this way it's beautiful
it's a real moment of excitement and
relief for the scientists involved
because the mission's finally on its way
and for the European Space Agency that's
never sent a dedicated mission to
Jupiter 4 before and certainly not one
with as many scientific instruments on
it as this it's very much just the first
step on a very long and perilous Journey
all the way to the Jupiter system
the Jupiter icy moons Explorer is
embarking on an eight year long 4
billion mile slow waltz through the
solar system several orbits of the Sun a
slingshot around the Moon and Earth
another round Venus are needed to get it
to Jupiter in 2031. once it arrives it
will perform flybys of Jupiter and three
of its moons Europa Callisto and
Ganymede some as close as 25 kilometers
to the surface
what it sees will be thanks to Engineers
here at Teledyne in Essex they made the
Imaging sensor induces camera No Easy
Task as radiation around Jupiter would
destroy conventional Electronics the
environment it sees at Jupiter is nasty
especially really really high radiation
so there's a high probability of
anything ordinary will fail and the
in-launch environment is quite nasty as
well so you've got to make sure it
survives launch survives the journey
there and it continues to work well in
the horrible environment that's around
Jupiter it is very exciting and
especially when it's the first image of
something that's never been imaged
before
other tools Radars and magnetometers
will peer into the ice covering
Jupiter's moons study their atmospheres
and measure tidal forces believed to
keep salt water oceans beneath warm and
liquid
could life like that found around deep
sea vents on Earth exist on the moons
orbiting our giant distant neighbor or
are we all alone
well watch this space
Tom Clark Sky News
now you can take your hands off the
wheel and your feet off the pedals but
you'll have to watch the road that's
because Britain has become the first
country in Europe to approve hands-free
driving technology the current question
is the Ford Mustang Mackie already being
used by motorists in the U.S Lisa Dowd
has been trying it out
this car is a first for British and
European motorways
press the blue Crews on
set the speed
there's a real feeling of sickness in
your stomach
you feel like you might go to either
side of the road but you don't it's
legal to let go but you can't look away
itself feels really odd
I'm just not looking at the road
and the alarm sounds it wants me to
watch the road ahead it's almost
driverless
driving isn't it but not quite it's
almost yeah so we're taking care of the
acceleration braking steering we figure
out where the lane markers are we react
to it
and
you don't need to keep your hands
the near region of the steering wheel
Tech is on board the newest electric
Ford Mustang Mac e nearly 200 000
drivers in the US and Canada have used
it without incident but some have
concern the key thing for us is ensuring
that the drivers themselves who buy
these cars know exactly what the car can
and cannot do and at the moment that's
all down to forward and there's no
government intervention and no
government training the government says
it shows the UK is at the Forefront of
innovation and Ford plans to roll out
blue cruise to more of its vehicles I
think it's all about just making the
whole Driving Experience better and
easier for our customers hands-free is
free at first then you'll have to like
it enough to pay 17 pounds 99 a month
for it
Lisa dailed Sky News Warwickshire
well that was Sky News at 10 coming up
we'll be taking a first look at
tomorrow's papers in the Press preview
including this story on the front of the
times their headline nurses set for more
strikes as Junior doctors push for joint
walkouts and tonight we're joined by
Daily Mirror Economist Susie Boniface
and Deputy editor of conservative home
Henry Hill there they are standing by
for us at join us after this short break
foreign
[Music]